on behalf of the Columbia School of
International and public affairs i want
to wish you all a warm welcome to the
13th annual david n Dinkins leadership
and public policy forum which focuses
this year on the theme of the economic
recovery of the cities my name is John
cotesworth I'm the Dean of sepa as we
call it I want to wish a specially warm
welcome to some of our distinguished
guests whom you will be hearing
throughout the afternoon if this were a
welcoming speech in China would be
called the speech of the three apologies
i have three to make the first is on
behalf of President Lee Bollinger of
Columbia University who is traveling in
Europe and unable to be here he wants me
to extend you his greetings and his
disappointment that he's not able to
attend this year's Dinkins form the
second is that I have a class in five
minutes and the Dean doesn't like
faculty missing classes are showing up
late so I'll have to be very brief in
these opening remarks I'll be back later
on in the afternoon and the third is
I've come back from the World Economic
Forum at Davos with a cold so if you
can't understand me that's the reason I
think somebody was trying to tell me
that it was time for me to finish
hobnobbing with the pooh-bahs and get
back to where I could do some good as
you know the purpose of the Incans forum
is to bring together educators
government officials and community
leaders to discuss the challenges facing
today cities in past years the forum has
addressed issues such critical issues as
urban education the urban environment
labor community building tourism the
transition from welfare to work urban
renewal the development of empowerment
zones the role of a firm affirmative
action in higher education the issue of
immigration and New York as a model for
global cities this year the forum will
focus on the impact of Barack Obama's
economic stimulus
package on the economic challenges of
the New York New Jersey Pennsylvania
region New York City Philadelphia
Trenton and Nassau Nassau County are the
focus of the panel discussions that
you'll hear this afternoon i will now
yield the podium to Mayor David Dinkins
founder of the Dinkins forum Mayor
Dinkins has been teaching at Columbia
University for the past 16 years in that
time Columbia has again become a real
center for research on urban problems
more than 350 Columbia faculty in every
part of the University are engaged in
research and/or service projects
relating to urban problems and issues
and more than half of them focus on the
new york city metropolitan region and
its surrounding neighbors that is
columbia university may have the largest
concentration of brainpower focused on
cities and city life anywhere in the
world just one of the reasons why sefa
is happy to host the Dickens form every
year and why the Dinkins forum is always
packed as you all know mayor Dinkins
began his career in public service in
1966 in the New York State Assembly he
also served as president of the New York
City Board of Elections and then city
clerk before his election as president
of the borough of Manhattan in 1985 he
became the first african-american mayor
of New York City in 1989 under his
leadership the city implemented safe
streets safe city cops and kids the
model criminal justice plan for reducing
crime and expanding opportunities for
the children of New York City and he
established the beacon schools as mayor
he significantly increased the city's
police force resulting in the first
decrease in crime in decades under his
leadership the city invested in
rehabilitating dilapidated low-income
housing in Harlem the South Bronx and
Brooklyn which resulted in revitalizing
once forgotten neighborhoods and
cleaning up Times Square I could go on
citing his accomplishments including how
much he has done
the city after he left the mayor's
office and was promoted to professor but
I have to run to class mayor Dinkins
it's my boss someone got to be
appropriately respectful I'm delighted
that he was able to take the time we we
realized that in future years what we
must do is commenced the form between
classes and so that we don't have this
kind of a problem but the Dean was good
enough to to come in even though he's
just back from traveling abroad and and
even though he as a class now I'm
especially pleased that the kino der
today is my brother I think this hardly
anyone in in new york city or its
environment doesn't know that Charlie
Rangel and I are brothers we are very
close Commissioner I look around the
room and I see a lot of folks that they
used to help me and and still do and
they make me look smart people think
that I'm really intelligent but I've
been doing this since I lost my other
job and and got evicted from public
housing that's what happened you know
but I am I am pleased to be here and I
know that I better get on with it
because we have of my teaching assistant
Rachel hair standing in the back I call
a doctor here because I want to get used
to her doctorate but she will soon have
and she gets very annoyed with me when i
get off message and said wandering
around and telling stories and that
right max and but but but i do have to
just tell you one story then i'll get
back to my script Charlie's mother
objected to him calling me brother
and said why do you call him your
brother he's not your brother you've had
one brother Ralph he's gone and but you
insist on calling the mayor your brother
Charlie tells us better than I do but
but since I'm up first so Charlie
explained we were close political and
personal friends and therefore we called
each other brother didn't satisfied mom
then it was Mother's Day and I sent her
flowers and a note which said since my
mother is gone and charlie is my brother
therefore you're my mother too from then
on I was tight with mom so much so so
much so that on one occasion she was
hospitalized I arrived before Charlie he
telephoned in and she said my other son
is here I knew I was all right then so I
have a million stories like that about
charlie rangel and me but I will not the
CEPA has redouble its efforts to marry
public policy with global concerns in
ways that of institutions have not
succeeded in doing always with the aim
of grooming global leaders and arming
them with a practical as well as
theoretical grounding as they span the
globe the world the nation and the
Academy are entering an especially
volatile period in 2010 and we at sea /
and at Columbia University look forward
to the deans continued stewardship as he
lends his considerable knowledge
expertise that support to our programs
including the Dinkins forum as you've
been told the topic of this hour 13
forum centers on the challenges facing
the nation cities as we struggle to
recover from the worst economic crisis
since the Great Depression and we have
assembled quite an outstanding group of
leaders
to help us address the issues I'm
grateful to Philadelphia Mayor Michael
Nutter Trenton mayor doug palmer and
former nassau county executive tom
suozzi for taking time from the
demanding task of running their cities
and other businesses to be with us today
and those of you who remain with us for
the second panel we're here from three
of New York City's finest public
servants all knowledgeable and
passionate about the state of the city
David Jones of the community service
society David is the first
african-american they had that
organization of I think it's about a
hundred and sixty years old David Jones
as a remarkable job and Kathryn Wylde of
the partnership for New York who used to
help me way back when I was borough
president of Manhattan you as you were
told by the Dean I used to be president
of the borough of Manhattan I ran three
times before I succeeded people used to
say to me what do you do and I'd say I
run for borough president and also we
are so pleased to have the deputy mayor
for economic development Robert Lieber
and I think it's very kind gracious of
him to agree to help us out our
panelists will shortly be properly and
thoroughly introduced by today's panel
chairs dr. ester Fuchs professor of
public affairs and political science and
a dear friend who's been assisting me
since day one and dr. Dorian Warren
assistant professor of political science
he's got youth on his side aside from
being very smart I thank them both for
conceptual advising the topic of this
form and from refining upon the key
issues so that we have time enough for
serious discussion and we must and we
are most grateful to them for urging the
participation of such distinguished
panelists dr. Fuchs one of sleepers most
prolific scholars and practice
business has taken time from her leave
to work as senior policy fellow with the
partnership for New York City to
participate in today's forum and we've
happy we are happy that she answered our
call it was not to Fuchs who gave life
to this forum some 15 years ago its
founding director of the center for
urban research and policy and she has
consistently played a major role in
bringing the most compelling public
policy issues to the floor for an airing
dr. Fuchs is no stranger to the inner
workings of city government having
served as mayor bloomberg special
advisor for governance and strategic
planning through his first term in
office a prolific author of works
including mayor's and money fiscal
policy in New York and Chicago she
recently contributed an essay on
innovations in city government the case
of New York City's workforce development
system to our case study series in
global public policy if her resume reads
if it taken from who's who in urban
policy that's because it is we here at
seaport gratified that she chose to
return to teaching and to give yet
another generation of sepa students a
benefit of her knowledge and her
experience as director of our urban
policy concentration you know folks here
the name School of International and
public affairs and they hear only
international and and they forget that
we are as concerned with public policy
as with international affairs that's why
some of us think that it's so important
that we have events like this forum
where we can talk about urban centers
and what's necessary I have the good
fortune of having a lot of friends who
serve me in government and made me look
smart who come and lecture for me here
and so our students are exposed to real
experts brilliant people who care about
our city
dr. Warren is many of you faculty and
students know is one of our finest
scholars of the study of inequality in
American politics and the politics of
Labor race and ethnicity and community
organizing one of the youngest and most
popular members of the faculties of sepa
and the political science department dr.
Warren focuses on the politics of
marginalized groups returning this year
from a research fellowship with the
Russell Sage Foundation dr. Warren is
also a fellow at the institute for
social and economic research and policy
and a faculty affiliate at the Institute
for Research in african-american studies
in his spare time he coordinates the
seminar series for the center for urban
research and policy and serves on our
law school Center for social and
institutional change he has written a
recent piece on the politics and
practice of economic justice and is
looking forward to what our panelists
are prepared to share with us about the
challenges that the current fiscal
crisis brains to policymakers in the
world's urban centers and the impact on
the daily lives of the working people
who live there the leaders of our urban
centers continue to press forward in
addressing the near tragic consequences
of the legacy of the disastrous bush
years more than 230 mayor's convened
last month in Washington at the winter
meeting of the United States Conference
of Mayors to discuss their efforts to
make some headway against the persistent
fiscal problems their cities and their
regions face and the accounts of that
discussion where sobering will no doubt
hear first-hand reports from two of our
panelists today incidentally the US
Conference of Mayors the official
nonpartisan organization of cities with
populations of 30,000 or more was
presided over by Mayor Doug Palmer for
the longest term since fiorello
laguardia in the 1930s
it he's so young that you wonder how he
was there that long incidentally he and
I were elected the same year he stayed
around a whole lot longer than I did
wasn't my idea but that's what happened
the paradox of poverty in the midst of
plenty is of course not a new one for
the working class but the current level
of unemployment is a phenomenon we have
not experienced since the Great
Depression and is increasingly an urban
crisis dr. Warren will chair panel one
the view from Philadelphia Nassau County
and Trenton and will halt upon Mayor
Nutter mayor Palmer and mr. swazi to
share their analyses and direction on
this topic and we thank them for giving
of their time to broaden our perspective
dr. Fuchs will chair our second panel on
the view from new york city and has
assembled another distinguished group
deputy mayor Lieber captain wild and
David Jones to discuss the and assess
the strategies this city has adopted for
economic recovery following each panel
presentation we would be interested in
some discussion of the problem with
those of you who have been observers and
participants and efforts to address the
issues and we are especially interested
in hearing the thoughts opinions and
questions of those students in our
audience our panel chairs will
reintroduce their respective families as
each session begins and I now have the
honor of presenting our keynote speaker
to set the tone of our discussion
charles Rangel has represented the 15th
congressional district for nearly 40
years and is Dean of a New York
congressional delegation over his entire
career in public service congressman
Rangel has been on one of the strongest
voices for the poor the sick the
uneducated and the unemployed in our
nation and has been in the leadership of
the fights for those
things that affect the most healthcare
reform affordable housing quality
education and jobs principal author of
the five billion dollar federal
empowerment zone program for
revitalization of local economies the
congressman has interfaced with the
nation's mayor's in the critical areas
of tax credits rehabilitation of public
school employment and joblessness and
housing and homelessness on
international stage has led the way in
promoting trade with Caribbean nations
including Cuba and the sub-saharan
Africa enforcing US corporations
withdraw from a part 8 South Africa and
is now spearheading legislation for
federal aid to haiti and today hundreds
of career diplomats in the field earned
their credentials and the charles Rangel
international affairs program housed at
howard university a leading player and
president obama's recovery initiatives
congressman Rangel brings to today's
discussion a wealth of insight and
experience in critiquing informing and
orchestrating public policies and
crafting programs to address the needs
of the people of the city of New York
and the nation and in seeking solutions
to long-standing systemic problems
elected chair of one of the most
powerful committees in the Congress he
has oversight of one of the most
critical conduits of funding in the
country our public policy students know
that the Ways and Means Committee has
authority over economic policy taxes
international trade welfare Social
Security Medicare and health care policy
and chairman Rangel is determined to use
his influential chairmanship to improve
the lives of the poor the working poor
and what remains of the middle class we
are honored to have the Chairman address
us we were honored to have the Chairman
address us at our fourth annual
forum on the topic of Culture and
Tourism tools for urban economic
development we are delighted to welcome
him back to speak with us today I might
add that the congressman has graciously
consented to a brief Q&A period for the
benefit of the many students of the
audience and now please join me in
welcoming our congressman and my brother
chairman charles v Rangel
brother hey Joyce my brother didn't
finish that story with the relationship
he enjoyed with my mother because I
thought it was very kind of her to to
sort of adopt my brother the way that
she did but it didn't work out that way
for long because instead of just saying
my son the Congress meant he became my
son the mayor and because a little
problem there but thank you David for
such a for your friendship most of all
for your guidance e of support and
making my political life and social life
a lot easier follow everything he does
normally five or ten years behind but
you you gotta such an exciting a program
that i'm going to try to make my remarks
brief so that i can take advantage of of
the questions that you have the mayor's
here from Trenton and Philadelphia Tom
Suozzi one of most outstanding public
servants that we have in this country
will be hearing from dr. Warren and
esther and is david jones and house and
the deputy mayor lieber i'm working with
them as he Moses that's hear from
Alexander Alexia the Dominican lancia he
does such a great job for so many thing
Mo's is if we didn't have you would have
to create you you really have been so
helpful to me so I'll tell you like Liz
Taylor tohe eight husband I won't keep
you long but uh oh hope to make it it's
exciting because I I wrote a book and
the title was and i haven't had a bad
day sense the title referred to the fact
on november 30 in the nineteen fifty was
in Korea on the Yellow River surrounded
by tens of thousands of
this Chinese shot left 4 dead and I
wasn't very religious up to that point
but i found my communications with God
and Jesus and everything and I made a
commitment that if I ever got out of
what a situation look like it was
impossible to get out of that I would
never complain about anything it's been
rough but I haven't truly had a bad day
since that and even as we go as we go
through this this economic recession the
depression for so many Americans with an
untested president and a partisan
Congress and so many people that are out
of work where their hopes and dreams
have been shattered as they lose their
jobs they lose their health insurance
many of them have cut off their
ambitions for they kids so many
Americans are going to college from the
first time have to cut all of that short
but at the same time we have the
opportunity to rebuild this great
country to move forward and exercise the
leadership that you can and will be
giving not just to Americans and
sometimes have forgotten their
commitments to each other but most
important a country blessed as we are
have an obligation to provide that
leadership to the world and in doing so
and maintaining democracy and improving
trade and education for all of our
people it makes the whole concept of
going to war invading countries and
trying to preserve what we call peace
and democracy when so many Americans and
other people are given up their lives
there is no questions that scholars
would be saying for decades following
our period here on earth that the
intrusions that we have in the Middle
East by having armies occupied countries
the lives that are lost the money that
is wasted could best be served
by having a better understanding that
this is our planet to share and to lead
and not one just to be dominated and so
we have a young president that comes
into office with a economy that is
shattered a world at war at least we're
at war and the ability to understand
what has to be done and the truth of the
matter is that it all starts in my
opinion with education I dropped out of
high school went to the service came
back GI Bill and now I had the Ways and
Means Committee the only difference
between that is education and now that
there's so many people that don't have
the training and technology to be able
to deal with this country after the
recovery what good is an economic
recovery if we don't have people that
are able to work and restore those
dreams that made America what she is and
by doing that if you take the areas that
this president has said that when the
investment is going to be made there's
some that says don't spend the money
just give it to the banks and let them
and capitalism be able to make the
recovery but if you do have the bankers
that are able to make the financial
recovery what have we lost as a country
if we don't have our students and our
workforce prepared to meet the technical
demands that we would have to compete
with in the future so what are we
talking about China whether we're
talking about India whether we talk
about math when we talking about science
what makes a country great is what we
think of ourselves our families our
communities and what we think about each
other and we have that great opportunity
by having a conference of mayors who
truly understand that while we are
working trying to change the
international world they have to deal
with these problems each and every day
it is just so insane to believe that a
country is great about as more people
locked up in jail than all of the
country
in the world and this is where we're
investing instead of making certain that
every kid every child that's born will
know that he or she could get the best
education that they want in the world
because indeed they pay it back not just
in talents but in income taxes world as
well and if we're talking about health
care what is there left to understand if
we find that this is 16 of a national
budget that we pay more than any other
country in terms of health care and
we're not there as the leaders in it oh
sure for the precious few they're able
to get it but to see the number of
people who die or contract diseases
chronic diseases merely because they
never had a chance to be involved in
preventive medicine never was able to
expose of these things what it means is
that as long as we have competitors that
are dealing with health care that are
dealing with the education and we have
to compete against them and the private
sector has to make these investments
it's impossible think that we would be
competitors and so we have the
opportunity under this great president
to move forward not only in investments
in education and health care but also in
technology and in the arts and the and
the areas that allow us to be the great
nation that we could be and certainly in
our inner cities to make certain that
the people that are born they have an
opportunity to compete with anybody in
the entire city anybody entire state
whatever region and whatever we have in
this country but it's up to us in a
sense to recognize that the tragedies
that happen to Haiti even though their
individual even though it's a country
even though it's a region see that in
part has been due to the indifference of
this part of the world in dealing with
the problems of poor nations it's a part
of the stigma of colonialism where we
have taken away the resources but not
install a sense of people being able to
rebuild their country
bill there people with the pride and
dignity as we find in the United Nations
and in the European Union but we can do
all of these things if we can find a
compassion that we have been able to
find for Haiti but find it in this
country it is just so difficult for me
to admit that one of the reasons and the
major reasons why we don't have national
health care today is because of an old
expression that you've heard over and
over I've got mine jack I've got mine
and people are so frightened the seventy
to seventy-five percent of the people
that have good health care that they
will be paying for those people that
don't have health care who are
underinsured by having to pay for them
when the truth of the matter is that
everybody insured brings down the course
the previous brings down the course of
health care and makes us all be on an
even playing field in what we do so we
have to participate and I'm glad that
Professor Dinkins has talked about the
international community in public
affairs it's not that much of a gap in
what we talking about it's going to be
the leaders in our local communities in
our cities and in state government
that's going to determine the direction
that this great country is going and
it's not enough to be silent your voices
have to be screaming out for census
counts it has to be there for education
it has to be there for those people who
don't have because we cannot be assured
that we will continue to enjoy the
benefits of a great country if other
people in that country don't have we are
indeed our brothers keepers whether
we're talking about Cuba whether we talk
about Africa or whether we're talking
about the inner cities and so I am so
glad to have this opportunity to share
my views and to share with you the
opportunities that you have you don't
have to be a member of Congress to
understand that we have to rebuild our
society and at this point in time we can
do it and making the changes that we
should have made three dec three
centuries ago
we can start now with a clean slate
rebuilding our schools rebuilding our
health system rebuilding that that
feeling that we've had when so many
people came to this country that we can
be good we can be better we can share
and we can have a better world and so I
hope that maybe one day you'll be able
to say that you haven't had a bad day
sense and that will be because of the
contributions that you'll be able to
make Thank You Dean Thank You mr. mayor
and thank you my fellow colleagues in
government for taking time out to share
your experience with this wonderful
audience and so I don't know my time
limits but whatever it is is in your
hands I'll take a couple of questions
and get out of here as soon as I can
thank you
yes I think ye yo D tonight when I'm
Bruce linking from Columbia School of
Engineering hello congressman rangel see
by the importance of broadband as a
drive for economic development job
creation in our urban areas please
there's no create no question that we
have been given a new opportunity I
remember not too long i guess it was a
long time ago my boys 40 years old but
hey i walked into the den and his
friends started laughing when I entered
and I said what the hell's so funny and
they refused to tell me and they were
watching television and finally I became
stirring and I told my son you know this
isn't funny you tell me what the heck
you laughing at he says well dad I had
already shared with my friends that you
told me that when you allow age how the
radio was just as exciting as our
televisions that is which means that
you'll never be able to explain
something to people who don't know what
it was like listening and enjoying radio
broadband office an opportunity not only
for us to bring our community in our
country together but to spread our
technology throughout the world I can't
begin to tell you what we are going to
be doing in the so-called green economy
what we're going to invest in making
certain that we not reliance on fossil
fuels what opportunities we're going to
have not only to control the climate but
to make certain that we create the jobs
and educate the people in the
technologies that's going to have a new
world I try to tell the younger people
that just as you don't know about the
horse and wagons as I do that one day
that this will become our way of life
broadband technology is going to guide
this great country even further than our
wildest dreams and I thank you so much
for bringing that up because math and
son
has to be something that's not
restricted to Asia that we got to find
its way somehow in our schools to have
that as a part of the regular curriculum
we can do it but most importantly we
have to do it yes sir my name is Miles
egg and I'm from your community Harlem
and I'm from the Rucker tournament and
as you know we lost Percy Sutton Hoo you
always talked to as a your best friend
and person I had talked about we fight
back a little bit in history about the
fact that Harlem did not get a fair
share of the new york city olympic bid I
know that for a fact because when you
look at the map etc etc we were not
getting anything but I must ask you a
personal question because I wrote a
paper and hand character to the mayor
and dr. all about the new york city
olympic bid and i must say quickly that
it's very important that everyone
understand that the Olympic Games one of
the most one of the most significant
urban development projects in the world
so the point is is that i wrote a paper
which hopefully you saw because you did
accompany the delegation to singapore
did you not yes I did forgot I wrote a
paper we treated Africa better we would
have gotten their votes instead of Great
Britain and we would have had the
Olympics but go ahead uh well it's just
really did you ever get well I'm sorry i
did had to set it up I'm awfully sorry
oh I've had grown sorry about that okay
did you get a chance to read the paper
on the trip which made its way into dr.
of speech on the Lord the history of
grassroots sports in new york city and
its relationship to the olympic bid and
why we were short you know why don't you
get in touch of my office i'll pull it
up but thank you oh my god thank you
that's what dr. when i'll in and i'll in
with your office was present when Andrew
Young came to Harlem and talked about
how he had control of two billion
dollars on the Atlanta bit then I'll get
the benefit of your thinking on that
okay great what's your name again Aiken
I know the gang okay get in touch with
me I got you yes ma'am congressman
rangel it's a real pleasure to have you
here thank you sure to see you and your
new svelte physique my job is keeping up
a wife said over 45 years I've lost
about 5,000 pounds my name is flora
Davidson I'm one of your constituents
I'm also a professor at Barnard College
of political science and urban studies
some of my students are here as a
political scientist I need to ask you a
political question the day after the
State of the Union our junior colloquium
and Urban Studies met and my colleague
and I asked the following question to
our students which turned out to be a
rhetorical question which is do you
remember what President Obama said last
night about cities mother was rhetorical
I don't have to respond go ahead so my
question to you is what is the subtext
because clearly there's no text about
the president and the national
government and its attitudes which we
thought we're going to be a little more
upfront about national urban policy well
I don't know whether it's true that
Democrats dominate our cities but
there's one thing that's abundantly
clear that our friends from the rural
and southern areas have managed to
capture more of the resources than per
capita extent expenses will believe
whether we were talking about defense
contracts most of you from cities would
know that Medicaid we pay fifty percent
in the city and state of New York and
and in other areas the federal
government pay seven and eighty percent
that's not a payoff but it's order to
get boats we have I don't know how many
members in the city of in New York about
14 or 15 congressman I was explaining to
the mayor's that in the rural areas most
of the
have 15 or 20 mayor's in the area and so
life is unfair when it comes to this
cockamamie constitution which is each
one of them two senators the whole thing
begins tilted not toward our cities our
cities are really the makers of culture
of money taxes and the the way the
resources are distributed have not
really been that fear the president went
out of his way to make a special appeal
to Republicans and southerners at the
State of the Union and this you have to
do maybe the first time but there's a
limit to how much you can give up in
terms of trying to move forward
bipartisanship unfortunately and
tragically it's not going to work in
this Congress they have already decided
that their national policy is going to
be just say no and so I think the
political message that the president has
made is that i'ma do the best I can to
get it bipartisan but the country has to
move forward and he did that at the
State of the Union and he retreats and
I'm looking forward to a very very
productive years we see that a ghost
national product has increased jobs i
hope this year will be coming back and
and and i think the president will feel
far more able to do the things that he
want to do thank for you questioning yes
sir first of all i want to say it's an
honor i think we have a whole lot of
resources here so maybe the guy in the
dark expensive suit will be the last one
on the line
I'll try to be as brief as a little
potatoes I will too first and foremost
with this whole tragedy that happened in
Haiti there's a lot of first of all they
were living a tragedy before the
earthquake yes and a lot of the chadha
bit was due to corruption within their
own government now what I'm saying is
that the United States seems to invest a
lot of money into when it comes to
bailing people out now I I'm for them
bailing out Haiti I am for them bailing
out try to try to create an a stimulus
package that is supposed to bail out the
American people but according to what I
see is that we continue bailing people
out that are within corruption in other
words Wall Street is corrupt Haiti
continues to have a corrupt government
that probably the money will not source
out to them my question is that how do
we get past the corruption should
actually help the people and what I'm
looking at is that I get paid when i get
paid my check comes out of my pocket I
don't even see the taxes are taken out
so in other words the money goes back to
the bank because Obama's cabinet along
with the rest of the United shtetl
United States seems to be about the
seems to be a lot of bankers and a lot
of Wall Street people now it never
leaves it always stays in a bank how do
we invest and how do we help people
without and avoid the people who walked
out the people who are other people that
hate haven't made out the bankers that
made out I guess save you money put it
in a mattress and just hope something
good happens a lot of it but the fact is
that when you help a country this isn't
all just gratuitous it is to help
somebody to be able to buy something
from you is to be able to say when you
go to the United Nations that you have
friends and realize that like
prostitution you need a prostitute and a
John to have corruption you need more
than one country that's involved in that
corruption you're right and to a large
extent America supported that policy
there you against communism you can do
what the heck you want I really think
this is an opportunity to change all of
those things in Haiti we got expanded
trade policy and when people are working
they don't have to
tolerate dictatorships and they have
more transparent governments and I think
if you listen to the president's State
of the Union you will see that he's
given talk more to bail out but in
helping the larger fiscal institutions
now we gotta turn toward the community
banks the small business where we should
have been and I think we can try to get
some confidence restored that this is a
great country with a dependent people
like you have to really keep those in
government whether it's here ovoid
honest don't give up I won't okay thank
you yes sir congressman and thanks for
coming I'm a dual degree student between
g7 planning and seba and sustainable
thank Colombia for the great job they
did in helping me with the empowerment
zones not just for my congressional
district web for the country go ahead so
clearly urban issues are very dear to me
and I salute the democrats and obama for
putting them back on the plate after so
many years of missing but at the same
time i see that there's some lack of
really addressing the underlying issues
that have led us to where we are and the
reasons for which we have this crisis
for example how the federal some housing
subsidy act really influences the move
people out of cities or that we haven't
increased the highway i excuse me the
fuel tax by a dime but transit has
increased by several quarters over the
last ten years so my question to you is
from a policy perspective how can we
convince people that we need to invest
money differently and to change not only
policies for the future but to question
policies we've had for the last half
century and to really address not just
the issues of today but the issues that
have led us to where we are today well
it takes a long time certainly we only
had one year of Obama we've had eight
years of people who who thought the
opposite of the things that that you
treasure to me every individual has a
right and obligation to be very
selective in the people that they put in
charge of these policies and so whether
it's done in a political way or whether
it's done with private organizations
that's concerned about the
climate concerned about the direction
which our great democracy like I was
going is that you have to participate
and when you have so many people not
participating it but complaining is
something wrong with that picture so
Obama's going through some pretty rough
times but no one is really talking about
what he inherited what the budget
surpluses 'it was winner banks were
where the job was and we stepping closer
to normality in terms of our fiscal
policy so we're not there yet and we got
to get people back to work and then we
can get to a an agenda that's more
related to you every day your hopes and
dreams thank you but participate yes sir
Thank You congressman my name is Vikas
ready I'm a PhD student at the teacher's
college here at Columbia University and
you mentioned education in your remarks
and this afternoon I believe President
Obama is outlining his budget proposal
for the coming year in which reportedly
education will receive the largest
federal increase since the passage of
the Elementary and Secondary Education
Act now given president obama's success
on some other elements of his domestic
agenda how do you especially from your
perch as chairman of ways and means how
do you see a way forward for this budget
and especially for what i would see is a
pretty critical piece this increased
education funding well we have to get it
through the republicans who really don't
look at education as the investment that
most people who have common sense would
realize that you're not enhancing the
individual you're enhancing the
community you're enhancing your country
when you find people who were supporting
issues on the bush but because it's
Barack Obama they just say no when you
find people that are changed and hold on
constitution in the Senate excuse me
where you need 60 votes where majority
has ruled for all of these centuries it
is a major problem I do hope that we
hear the voices
of those people that are prepared to
really give us the political support we
need with the budget it's difficult but
it's an investment and we get the money
back not only from me educational
investment point of view but we get it
back in income tax people who learn more
able to produce more make more money get
more taxes it pays for itself so get
your education it helped someone else to
get this it's so important hey I
chairman wrangle how you doing I'm thank
you for coming out a Michael Jackson of
PhD student here in the political
science department no relation and I
just want to say as a child of Mayor
another's neighbor Camden New Jersey I
going to show you this is not an
expensive suit at all please we were we
were fortunate to see a very interesting
and very insightful conference with
Obama and proud of the GOP last week and
I wanted to know what do we need to do
what can you do so that we can have an
American question time and see that kind
of thing with presidents and members of
Congress in the future say that the last
part of your question well I wanted to
see what what do we need to do and what
can the Congress do to have a question
time with the president much like Canada
and Britain has because that was a very
interesting press conference where we
got to see what the opposition thinks
and and when we don't have that form of
government where individuals can of
questioning the chief of State's gives
me but we do have something that is
similar that is that you have 139
members of Congress that have a two-year
contract and you don't have to be right
in order to kick him out of office what
you saw with the president however he
walked into the Republicans lines dead
to say hey this is my plan for the
country it's not a Republican
chronic plan but I need your help in
order to make certain that we do this
tragically and unfortunately and as
swazi in the mayor's know sometimes your
opposition finds it's better just to say
no than it is to work with you and try
to get positive things done so there's
two different things you're talking
about the first thing you're talking
about is the president of the United
States walking into the Republican
leadership as they had their retreat and
say what's wrong with my programs and I
think you would admit that they were
embarrassed more than they were taking
it the second thing is that you got to
take advantage of the Constitution I
mean obviously I'm not a candidate for
term limits but term
but term limits is in your hands you can
have a you know a lot of people get
their due there two years and the people
said that's enough we want someone know
so I can't think of anything better to
tell you then to have an educated
community have them to know the issues
have them to register and for God's sake
no matter how they vote let the Congress
know that you're interested that you
following them because the best way to
have a good government is the mixer that
you involved in that government let me
thank all of you for this wonderful
opportunity good to see you the doctor
again thank you my brother for giving me
this opportunity I wish I could stay
here for the mayor's but you know that
I'm with you and I'm with the conference
mayors and tom suozzi whatever you do
count me in